the world health organization has
published its conclusions into
the origins of the coronavirus pandemic
it found
that it's most likely that covid19 was
transmitted from
bats to humans via an unidentified
animal
but the director general of the who says
he believes this assessment requires
further investigation
and that all hypotheses remain on the
table
well we can take a look now at the
report's findings investigators say the
theory that the virus started due to a
leak from a lab is extremely
unlikely they say it's likely to very
likely that the virus was transmitted
from
animals although it's not clear how it's
spread to humans
and the report draws no firm conclusion
on the source of the virus
despite members of the investigation
team saying a so-called wet market
in the chinese city of wuhan was the
most
likely original source where we can
bring in our asia correspondent now tom
cheshire he's in beijing for us
so tom the who says a laboratory leak
is the least likely hypothesis for the
pandemic but they did also acknowledge
that they
had difficulties compiling this report
because we know that they weren't uh
able to see everything they wanted to
when they came to china
exactly i mean a lot of what we've got
in this report uh it was pretty scripted
we'd expected it was very similar to
what they said in the press conference
in wuhan
where we were in february uh these are
the findings they sort of reiterated
them what's very new what's
very surprising is that after this
report has been published
the head of the world health
organization has made his own remarks
uh released in a press release earlier
and he's really set fire to this report
to all intents and purposes
talking about that lab leak hypothesis
which they said wouldn't require further
investigation in the official wha report
dr chadros says i believe this
assessment was not
extensive enough further data and
studies will be needed to reach
more robust conclusions although the
team has concluded the laboratory leak
is the least likely hypothesis
this requires further investigation
potential with additional missions
involving specialist experts
which i am ready to deploy i mean this
is extraordinary in two ways first of
all this report has been a long time in
the making and this is the head of the
welfare held
health organization saying well actually
this isn't good enough
but second what this means for china dr
tedros has been renowned for his
diplomatic approach some say the who
have been giving in too much to china
from the start of the pandemic
not pushing them hard enough because
they didn't want to lose cooperation in
the midst of a pandemic
now that seems to have changed as far as
beijing was concerned this report
meant it was job done they said they'd
been open and transparent they were
calling on the w.o
to go to america to investigate
laboratories there now the head of the
who
is saying he's ready to send another
mission to china specifically
to look at whether covid19 came from a
chinese
virus laboratory that is a really really
crucial crucial intervention it's going
to make beijing very very angry i
imagine
we'll hear from them very soon it won't
take as long as it usually takes from on
these
on these matters but this is it is
really hard to say
how much of an intervention this is this
is going to change a lot of the thinking
around covid
that this lab hypothesis needs further
investigation in a very very serious way
i don't think it's what anyone was
expecting from what had looked like
quite a bland report fascinating tom in
beijing
thank you very much